god save the king
[Music]
the change was immediate for a man who
always knew this time would come
the cameras allowed in like never before
so we could understand how he felt about
her
and what he's taken on
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
i too now
solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time god grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
scott fezzindenwood the british high
commissioner to barbados
was charles's deputy private secretary
for four years and believes the man he
knows well has acted quickly to squash
suggestions he'll be a meddling monarch
as king
he will do things differently it's a
very different job but i think we'll
still see those those same
instincts that same desire to want to
use his role appropriately but to use
his role in a way which makes a
difference to to this country makes a
difference in the commonwealth
and does uh does a service i
charles prince of wales there are no
rules for how he should reign but he had
the best of teachers
the queen guiding him towards the role
that would eventually be his
it shaped a man who always keeps his
police officers on their toes the
walkabouts this week coming naturally as
he showed us he wasn't just going to do
what was expected but what matters to
him the sovereign has an additional duty
less formally recognized
but
to be no less diligently discharged
it is the duty to protect the diversity
of our country
on the world stage she will be a hard
act to follow very rarely putting a foot
wrong
the rolling cameras haven't always been
as forgiving for her son
inkwells and pens bearing the brunt
and in some ways showing why the new
king and the institution still has work
to do
we have to pay for your parade and why
the pneumonic has needed his family
getting the right tone in this moment
was always going to be potentially
difficult for king charles but what we
have seen this week is how the entire
family also want to step up to help in
every one of their tributes to the queen
they also mention their brother their
father their uncle and their support for
the new king
publicly he has united them but it is
still the queen that has brought the
world together
now that heaviest of responsibilities
rests with her son
finally it is his time to lead
rhiannon mills sky news in central
london